l'essentiel est dans le corps on ne voit
qu'avec le coeur pourquoi parce que
l'essentiel est invisible pour les yeux
antoine saint-exupéry en grandes mains
justement ce dont je veux vous parler
aujourd'hui il est invisible qu'il est
subtile il est même sacré ce dont je
vais vous parler c'est ce que nous
sommes réellement c'est la vie en nous
il ya un espace intérieur que nous avons
souvent oubliés qui est notre être
profond de notre être d'amour et de paix
et notre raison d'être profonde alors
nous allons faire une visite à cet être
prendre un contact avec lui et je vais
vous demander de fermer les yeux
ça va durer trois minutes alors
essayez d'être d'avoir le dos droit sont
raideur dans la souplesse
posez vos mains sur vos cuisses du façon
confortable
tel que vous le sentez et porter votre
attention sur votre respiration expire
expire inspire expire porte votre
attention sur ce ter qui rentrent par
vos narines qui on lit vos poumons et
qui se diffuse dont votre corps en
apportant une énergie vitale jusqu'au
bout de vos cellules
alex pire
alex pire à l'expiration imaginé cette
terre qui quitte votre corps et qui a
nettoyé vos cellules et qui ressort par
votre nez fait ça trois fois inspire et
expire inspire expire est resté focalisé
sur votre souffle sont le modifier vous
êtes là pour l'observer et l'accompagner
avant d'ouvrir les yeux remercier ce
miracle que vous êtes remercier cet être
intérieur cette mécanique génial et vous
pouvez ouvrir maintenant les yeux notre
raison d'être profonde notre nature
profonde
c'est une présence intérieure
cette présence moi je l' ai découvert
avec un grand m elle en 2001 en france
au cours d'une retraite spirituelle tic
nhat hanh
c'est un grand bonhomme je veux juste
vous résumer un peu sa vie
je lui vaut bien cet hommage il a il
vietnam et 1
il a combattu les américains par la non
violence
il a rejoint et s'est exilé en france en
1965 il a été proposé à en belgique à
une grande
un honneur de paix mais malheureusement
celui qui l'a proposée qui est martin
luther king ont 68 il a été assassiné et
donc ça n'a pas pu se faire
aujourd'hui il a 90 ans il est toujours
dans la région de bordeaux au village
des pruniers
il enseigne toujours le zen il cultive
son jardin effet sa marche quotidienne
alors cette présence qu'est ce que c'est
que cette présence la présence c'est la
vie c'est quelque chose qui ne nous
quitte jamais la vie est une succession
de moments présents ni feature ni passé
le passé c'est juste une pensée c'est un
souvenir le futur n'existe pas encore
tout ce qui existe et ce moment 13 ans
qui est là et qui nous permet d'agir
est-ce que vous pouvez agir dans le
passé non vous ne pouvez pas non plus
agir dans le futur impossible donc nous
vivons constamment un moment présent qui
qui est là et c'est une succession de
moments présents et la vie s'éteint et
dans le présent elle est ni dans le
futur né dans le passé alors pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à être dans le présent
parce que nous avons en nous ce qu'on
appelle le mental le mental même pas le
présent parce que sa nourriture ce sont
les pensées sont les pensées il n'existe
pas observez comment le mental
vous fait souffrir avec des souvenirs du
passé et comment ils vous angoisse avec
le avec l'inconnue du futur donc pour
être dans la vie vraie dans le présent
le futur et le passé ne sont en fait que
des illusions
le présent c'est la seule réalité qui
existe
le mental est un excellent serviteur ça
nous permet de réfléchir d'être
interface avec la société
mais tant qu'il est serviteur il est
utile pour nous mais le problème c'est
que le mental quand vous êtes dans la
présence il a besoin de manger dépenser
alors qu'est ce qu'il fait et vous
invente n'importe quoi il vous fait
rappeler des mauvais souvenirs du passé
pour ça à la machine continue à tourner
ou alors il faut créer des scénarios
catastrophes sur l'avenir demain
après-demain à partir d'un petit détail
de rien du tout il vaut construit tout
un cinéma alors qu'au fait ça ne se
passe que dans la tête
au point où nous prenons ça pour de la
réalité
vous pouvez être chez vous allongée sur
le lit
vous rappelez un mauvais souvenir et
vous avez exactement les mêmes émotions
que vous avez eu disons avant vous
pouvez continuer à transpirer
alors que ça se passe uniquement dans la
tête là il a pris le pouvoir il est
devenu le maître
ainsi le mental est un très bon
serviteur mais c'est un redoutable m
alors comment
revenir comment comment faire de sorte
que le mental revient à ce qui doit être
un serviteur belge de vous raconter mon
histoire de vie quand j'étais enfant
j'étais quand j'avais 5 ans j'étais un
enfant très heureux j'étais dans le
présent
je ne pensais n'y a eu hier ni à demain
comment perm achetés grâce c'est quand
je mangeais la glace j'étais glace quand
je prenais mon vin avec mon petit bateau
rouge j'étais bateau roues et eau chaude
quand j'étais avec papa et maman dont
l'affection
j'étais amour à femmes
papa et maman cgt toujours dans le
présent vous étiez tout comme sa maman
peut m'appeler si je suis en train de
jouer peut m'appeler dix fois je
l'entendrai pas je répondrai pas parce
que je vais plonger dans mon ego
d'hommes en lego ou je suis plongé dans
un jeu qui me captive et je suis dans la
vigilance du moment présent
plus tard je reçus une première couche
demande au nom de mon éducation
parentale maman me disait tu dois faire
ceci et pas cela alors que moi je
brûlais d'envié de faire ceci et pas
seul à les contrarier les contrariétés
commencé à ce qui est encore pire c'est
les réponses de ma maman
des fois quand je lui posais une
question dont je vous voyez que les
termes
un peu triste eut demandé maman tu es
triste je le sentais maman me répondait
mais pas du tout je suis heureuse et là
encore une contrariété parce que moi je
sentais que maman été triste elle pour
me protéger mais je suis heureuse mais
qui croire mes sentiments houle ou les
autres alors j'ai commencé à en fermer
mes sentiments parce que je dis non
c'est pas moi qui a raison c'est
toujours les autres
et puis j'ai tu mets mes sentiments
après je ne m'exprimais pas et je les
gêner le couvercle sur les sentiments
troisième couche
mes croyances limitantes manar lui est
arrivé de me dire ne joue pas avec les
les enfants du voisin parce qu'ils sont
plus grandes que toi mais moi je dans ma
tête
à cet âge-là je comprenais le monde et
le monde extérieur est dangereux au
point où je pouvais plus sortir seuls
dix bons monde extérieur est agressif il
kim on veut donc l'aco qui se ferme et
encore de plus en plus sur moi alors
arrive à une troisième couche
qui est celle de mon éducation sociétal
dont la société
et là je vous assure c'était je me
croyais dans un dans un bal
parce qu'il fallait avoir un stock de
masques et m chaque fois à masquer
différents en fonction de celui qui est
en face en fonction de la situation peut
changer de masque parce que tout ça pour
être acceptée par la société
je ne pouvais pas être moi même parce
que moi je ne sais pas comme ça que je
pensais mes sentiments nous donner un
autre message
alors pour cacher ce message je m'adapte
et aux autres au point où à la fin je ne
savais plus qui j'étais
est ce que j'étais ce masque le masque
du camp je m'adressais à à mon
professeur ou à quelqu'un je voulais pas
ou alors j'étais un autre masse donc il
y avait plein de masques mais moins réel
manger tu n'étais pas assez mal aux
cadres des masques quatrième couche mes
émotions
alors là je peux vous dire c'est une
couche épaisse et gluante
elle colle à la peau les émotions ont
pour racines mes blessures d'enfance
ce sont des ressentis qui ont été
étouffés mecs sont imprimées dans le
corps on dit que ceux qui ne cessent eux
qui ne s'exprime se compriment et
s'imprime dans le corps d'ailleurs les
émotions on l'a démontré aujourd'hui que
les émotions sont responsables de
beaucoup de maladies
notamment le concert parce que ça crée
un dysfonctionnement des cellules et ça
provoque par contre des sécrétions de
toxines qui ne sont pas le
fonctionnement normal des cellules il ya
à une déstabilisation du code génétique
des cellules la cellule devient folle au
lieu de la cellule deux fois doivent
fabriquer une fois la cellule de du
poumon doit fabriquer du tissu de paume
en mai la cellule qui a un problème
fabrique n'importe quoi à quelque chose
qui ne ressemble à rien du tout parce
que hélas été déstabilisée et son code
génétique a été brouillé la masse qui se
crée si la tumeur maligne du cancer
c'est une excroissance alors l'enfant
qui était joyeux et qui qui était dans
le bonheur son élan de vie s'exprimer
comme ça comme un saltimbanque
il est heureux après les couches les
quatre couches qu'il a subie lorsqu'il
était venu adultes pratiquement son élan
de vie avec la carapace qu'il a eue
s'exprime comme ça
alors où est ce qu'il est passé sept
enfants aujourd'hui adultes notre enfant
il est toujours en nous cet élan de joie
et d'enthousiasmé
il existe toujours en nous c'est notre
espace intérieur
c'est notre être intérieur parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on est né et c'est
comme ça qu'on doit être alors comment
retrouver le le petit train est ce que
nous étions comment retrouver la joie
qu'on a vécu est le bonheur qu'on a on a
eu quand on était enfants avant d'être
en faire mais dans la carapace pour
retrouver cet état a trouvé cet être cet
espace intérieur
chez nous il faudrait s'intéresser un
peu plus à ce que nous sommes réellement
à notre raison d'être profonde
il faut ouvrir son corps son corps pour
laisser pénétrer la lumière qui va nous
éclairer de l'intérieur et de prendre
conscience de ce qu'on est réellement
alors pour retrouver
cet enfant il faudrait faire un chemin
un chemin spirituel
j'entends par spirituel c'est uniquement
la connaissance de soi et ce qu'on est
réellement parce que nous ne sommes pas
nous ne sont pas des êtres humains
[Musique]
vivent une expérience spirituelle sur
cette terre nous sommes des êtres
spirituels vivons une expérience dans
une forme humaine
voilà ce que nous sommes réellement
alors la voie spirituelle c'est la voix
de l'éveil se réveiller j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure de l'illusion du passé et de
l'avenir mais nous sommes endormis
nous sommes dans l'illusion dont 90%
dans notre temps en nous il ya deux
êtres
il ya un être qui est réveillé dans
l'obscurité
c'est le mental les pensées légaux ce
que nous sommes pas c'est la marionnette
qu'on a construite avec tout ce qui a
été avec toutes ces couches la savez on
est comme on est tous des gp tôt donc on
essaie geppetto il a fabriqué une
figurine pinocchio et après il s'est
pris pour pinocchio pour la faire pour
la figurine alors nous sommes donc nous
sommes
intérieurement deux êtres à naître qui
est réveillé dans l'obscurité
et un être qui est endormi dans la
lumière alors leurs élèves et
spirituelle pour revenir l'enfant qu'on
était heureux joyeux etc
il consiste à laisser dormir lettre qui
est réveillé mais dans l'obscurité et a
réveillé lettre qui est endormi dans la
lumière tout le chemin spirituel le
chemin du bonheur il déjà en plus de ça
ce passage de lettres endormi à l'être
éveiller ou réveiller
si la définition la dre définition de la
liberté la liberté par rapport à toi
devenir libre c'est pas dire n'importe
quoi n'importe tout ce qu'on veut ne pas
dire tout ce qu'on veut
là on veut et quand on veut c'est pas ça
la vraie liberté la liberté la dre
liberté est une liberté intérieure se
libérer par rapport au mental qui nous
fait souffrir avec la marionnette que
nous avons construit c'est ça la vraie
liberté
on peut être libre dans une prison vous
avez deux personnes dans une prison il
ya un qui regarde les barons et l'autre
ils regardent le ciel soleil qui est le
plus libre ils sont dans la même prison
et vous en connaissez je peux vous
donner des exemples monde est là il
était en prison pendant plus de 25 ans
mais c'était un homme libre dans la
prison
c'est pour ça qu'après il a pu faire ce
qu'il a fait pour vesti on peut citer
randy qui a été emprisonné plusieurs
fois et qui a lutté par la non violence
contre les anglais
il était toujours libre dans une prison
donc la liberté intérieure par rapport à
ce qui nous fait souffrir par rapport à
notre mental notre ego c'est la vraie
liberté
le disons que passé ce compte quand on
arrive donc à cet éveil spirituel et à
être libres libres de notre dictateur
intérieur on est en chemin vers le
bonheur
c'est un chemin très long
c'est un chemin très long mais ça m'a
pris peut-être disons mettant 15 ans
mais quand vous y arrivez
c'est si non seulement c'est plus que le
bonheur parce que vous êtes tellement
transparent que tout ce que vous pour
tout ce que vous voulez intérieurement
vous arrive sans vous rendre compte il
ya des synchronicité extraordinaire donc
le chemin spirituel est une voie vers
l'éveil et vers la liberté intérieure
je on va vous demander de conclure si
nadine parce qu'on a dépassé les 20
minutes de deux minutes je vous
l'accordé
alors bien sûr je vais résumer la femme
ce que nous sommes tous
alors ce que je voulais dire c'est que
toutes les avait constaté que toutes les
rivières du monde converge vers la mer
une fois que la rivière areva arrive à
la mère elle devient mère et devient
mère est une rivière
donc ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
nous ne sommes pas vous n'êtes pas une
goutte d'eau dans la dans la mer dans
l'océan
vous êtes l'on sait en tout entier dans
une douce merci pour votre présence
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de gamers